- Is George Pickens underrated?
Whoo-hoo-hoo! He laid out, Clint!
- He sold out.
- Horizontal! My guy,
Pickens power!
Welcome to "Underrated," the only show
that improves the video game ratings
of your favorite professional athletes.
Today, behind me, the tenacious rookie wide
receiver for the Pittsburgh Steelers,
George Pickens.
All right, so, your whole life,
you probably played Madden.
- Yeah.
- And now you're in the NFL.
Are you excited
to see yourself in the game?
- Yeah.
- What is that gonna be like?
- It's gonna be kinda crazy cuz,
you know, we didn't really have
NCAA in college.
- No.
- It's gonna be fun to play with yourself in the game,
even though I'm gonna be, you know, a rookie.
- You're expecting your ratings to be low?
- Yeah.
- Will it upset you when you see how low
they are, or will you use that as motivation?
- It won't upset me
unless it was, like, OD.
Like, if I was, like, a 50 or something like that.
- Mmm.
- It wouldn't really upset me cuz it's expected as a rookie.
- Yes.
I wish I was already, like, a 85.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- I don't think I can get you to that.
- But I do have a guy
that can get you up a little bit.
OK.
- So let's bring Clint Oldenburg in.
Get over here, Clint.
Where are we right now with George?
- Well, we're really excited
to see George play this year.
His catch ratings are actually pretty high.
He's in the mid-80s
for all of our catch—
and he's actually one of the top three
ranked receivers in all those categories.
- Yes, sir.
- But out of rookies?
- Out of all the rookies, yes.
- 85, 84?
- 84-85
range for spec catch.
- There's your 85.
- So, pretty good.
- And I'm—I'll take it.
- OK.
- [Clint:] Pretty good catching as a rookie.
- I love that.
- Right.
- So what can we work on today?
- Well, we wanna look at blocking.
- Mmm.
- [Clint:] Yeah, so
there's two main ratings
that we're looking at.
So, first is impact blocking.
- [George:] Yeah.
- [Clint:] Forty-seven, so that's 90th among all NFL wide
receivers, not just rookies.
- [Lefkoe:] OK.
- And then the second one is hit power.
Now, this is the one that needs
the most work.
- [George:] Yeah.
- [Clint:] Hit power right now is only an 18.
- [George:] Yeah. I'm gonna get that up.
- [Lefkoe:] Eighteen?!
- [Clint:] Eighteen.
- Mine would be an 18!
- I think you might be, like, an eight.
- We're not gonna get into that now.
So we can improve hit power and impact
blocking.
- Yes, sir.
- OK. You ready to do this?
- Let's do it.
- Yeah. Let's mess these ratings up.
- Eight.
All right,
George, we have a gauntlet of obstacles.
Try and maintain your line.
Block 'em as you go through,
and destroy these at the end.
I wanna see full anger.
- OK.
- [Lefkoe:] The clock goin'.
We're doing speed. We're doing power.
- [George:] Y'all ready?
- Three, two, one…go!
- Oh. Ah! Ah!
- [Lefkoe:] Oooh!
He stumbled,
and he's still smashing. Ooh!
Whoo-hoo-hoo! He laid out, Clint!
- He sold out. He sold out.
- Horizontal.
My guy, Pickens power!
I was very impressed.
How did it feel?
- It felt great.
- How did you feel about that?
- Sold out at the, at the tackle point,
that was great.
But I think if you give it one more try,
you might even be faster.
- Yeah, I think, I think I should give it
another try as well.
- You think so?
- Yeah. It might be better speed.
- I like that commitment.
All right, get out there.
- Let's do it.
- Destroy them.
Here we go, George.
Three, two, one, go!
Ooh. You see how far the balls are goin'
this time?
Oh, he's ready for it.
Yes. Ooh, and he hit that guy!
- [Clint:] He got that experience.
- [Lefkoe:] Boom! Let's go.
- He got that experience.
- How fast?
- Ten seconds.
- Ten seconds!
- That's pretty good.
- I felt like that time
you knew that they were coming at you.
- Yeah,
- I felt like they were flyin'.
And then you still laid out again.
You did that in 10 seconds.
- Wow.
- How did you feel about your performance?
- I felt like I did better than the last time.
- Mm.
He's writing a lot.
- I like that.
Clint's a great guy.
- We're in the lab over here.
- All right, so what are we thinking here?
- All right, so that second run
was even better than the first.
- [Lefkoe:] Yes, it was.
- It was a 10-second run.
Pretty good.
- He didn't even have to do that,
but he did it for you.
- Nailed every ball and actually hit some people with the beach balls.
- [Lefkoe:] Yeah, they looked like they got hurt.
- [Clint:] Right.
So, I think we might have some adjustments to make.
- Mm.
Here's the question that I love to ask:
- [Laughing]
- Hey, Clint Oldenurg,
is George Pickens underrated?
- George Pickens is underrated.
- [Singing] Tell us how much he's underrated.
[Singing] It's George Pickens. Come on!
Where was he, Clint?
- All right, so—
- Where's he goin', Clint?
- George was 47 at impact block?
- Yes.
- And even though he did a great job
with those balls, he went up
just one point in impact blocking to 48.
That ties him with Drake London
as the No. 1-rated—
- [Lefkoe whispering:] It'll get higher as the season goes—
- [Clint:] Wide receiver.
- No. 1 rookie wide receiver?!
- No. 1 rookie wide receiver.
- OK. OK. OK.
- [Clint:] Now, because of the aggressiveness
shown on the tackle
dummy over there, we're gonna go up
plus three on hit power.
- [George:] Yeahhh!
- [Lefkoe imitating George:] Yeahhh!
- So we're now, going into
Madden 23,
we're gonna be at 21 hit power
with receivers.
- [Lefkoe:] Hit power!
You do not wanna mess with George
Pickens.
He's gonna impact block ya.
He's gonna hit power.
And he is what?
- Underrated.
- Most importantly.
- Let's go, George!
- Whoo!